where already nine out of ten adults
have had one jab seven out of ten have
had two jabs and today we have an
opportunity to go further to take a
further step because our independent
committee of experts the the joint
committee on vaccinations and
immunizations has given a firm
recommendation to the government that we
should extend our offer of vaccinations
to all 16 and 17 year olds as universal
offer to 16 and 17 year olds and i've
decided to accept their recommendations
and i've asked the nhs to prepare to
deliver those vaccinations to 16 and 17
year olds as soon as possible can you be
sure that the benefits do now outweigh
the risks what reassurance can you give
to parents for example who might be
concerned the reassurance that we can
give actually comes directly from the
clinicians themselves so they've held a
press conference today as well where
we've heard from the deputy chief
medical officer the head of the jcvi and
uh dr june rain the head of the mhra our
independent uh medicines regulator and
they are all at one on this that this is
a absolutely the right thing to do uh
for all 16 and 17 year olds of course
there's no compulsion in this like all
our vaccination offer it's something for
people to consider and to decide if
there's something they want to do but we
want to make sure that all the best
information is available and that we are
doing all we can together to build this
wall of defense that already has meant
for example that there's 60 000 fewer
people in the uk that have died from
this
this horrid virus and also some 22
million infections have been prevented
all because of our vaccination program
and what about consent because 16 and 17
year olds will need consent from their
parents won't they and what if parents
won't give that consent but the
teenagers want it uh 16 and 17 year olds
won't need consent from their parents
and that's because already in in the uk
when it comes to medication 16 and 17
year olds can decide for themselves it's
uh the general presumption is that
they're just able to make these
decisions and and that hasn't changed so
they'll be able to decide for themselves
of course they may want to speak to
their parents and speak to others they
may want to speak to clinicians and
we'll be making sure that they have all
the information that they need and when
are you going to roll this out and how
will you roll it out
we had already been preparing for
something like this possibly happening
of course we weren't uh to know until
there's a decision by the experts but
now that they've made that decision on
16 and 17 year olds
we can put that into action and i hope
that we can be offering this very soon
certainly this month and might the age
go even lower
whether it's extended further uh you're
from 16 or 70 year olds to to children
that's a decision for the independent
jcvi it's not going to be a decision for
ministers so it will always be
clinically led i should point out though
a few weeks back the jcvi did advise
government that for those 12 to 15 year
olds
that are at risk particularly at risk
from covid that they are offered
vaccinations and also those children
that might live with adults that are
immunosuppressed and also for 17 year
olds that were approaching their 18th
birthday now we accepted that i accepted
that at the time and that's already
being rolled out but today's
announcement builds on that and just
finally to clarify when do you think the
first 16 year old will be able to get
their jobs how long it will be this
month and so the way we're going to roll
this out i think as people would expect
is working through the clinicians
working through gps through the primary
care networks and also we will use
hospital hubs we will use hubs like this
in bournemouth today that i visited that
i was very impressed by and also will be
working through the already existing
schools vaccination program which i
think will help to bolster this